le recteur d'académie qui dans son cas
directeur serait tranquille inquiet
avant d'aller à la rencontre des 5800
professeur de l'île et des 74 mille
écoliers serein surtout heureux de
retrouver l'ensemble du personnel et des
élèves pour une nouvelle année de
formation de découverte d'apprentissage
d'évolution des uns et des autres et
puis une année de projets aussi puisque
depuis six mois que je suis arrivé on a
lancé l'académie sur un certain nombre
de projets innovants expérimentaux avec
évidemment je vous cacherais pas ou s'il
est pas d inquiétude forcément mais des
interrogations notamment sur cette
rentrée mais je pose comment on va en
discuter
c'est votre première rentrée pascal jan
alors il ya des dossiers qui seront plus
particulièrement agité les syndicats ne
digère pas la réduction du nombre de
contrats aidés 929 l'an dernier 763 pour
2018 2019 pilule ne passera pas les
centrales syndicales ont déjà annoncé
que proposez vous demander une rallonge
par exemple à l'état alors il faut
d'abord replacer le cadre de la baisse
des contrats aidés dans le cadre de la
politique nationale où ça a été annoncé
très clairement par l'exécutif et
notamment en conseil des ministres il ya
un assèchement voulu de ce type de
contrat par les revers d'autres types de
contrats peut-être plus sécurisante plus
plus formateur pour le moment on est
dans un entre deux
la réalité c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
dotation qui nous a été alloué 2 563
donc effectivement il ya une baisse
c'est une réalité ou pas là il faut pas
la gâcher
mais c'est une baisse qui doit être
regardée j'allais dire de façon
objective
lilian que ça ne peut pas satisfaire
puisque on est on est en négatif mais
néanmoins
tous les directeurs d'école ont une
assistance administrative ce qui était
demandé par les directeurs d'école
compte tenu de leurs charges qui est
très lourde et diversifiée et par
rapport au second degré sert collèges et
lycées
c'est là que ça fait mais la réalité
c'est la suivante c'est que par rapport
à 2010 est on est en déficit 2 - 147
contrats contrats aidés puisque par
ailleurs on a recruté on a eu une
allocation des sachets on a recruté des
ave sage qui permet en réalité en tout
cas s'agissant de tous les emplois qui
pourraient aider les enfants handicapés
d'être tout à fait jaillir à l'aise par
rapport à ça donc la réalité c'est pas
moins - 400 art et essai par rapport aux
épées le effectivement ils nous on n'a
qu'un contingent de 214
alors j'ai déjà reçu il ya quelques
jours les ordres et les organisations
syndicales pour un petit peu a évoqué
très librement et clairement ses sujets
avant la rentrée évidemment il y met des
critiques mais aussi des doutes sur le
climat scolaire et les répercussions sur
le climat scolaire ce qui est tout à
fait légitime puisque l'on sait
pertinemment que ces contrats et des
participants de la migration du contrat
serait ce qu est ce que le recteur pu
être tentés de demander une rallonge
alors avant de vous dire ce que j'ai
demandé puisque effectivement j'ai
demandé une rallonge
la rallonge que j'ai demandé ces 147
puisqu'on est en en difficile de 147
pour les opérer par rapport à l'an passé
mais il ya aussi d'autres solutions
c'est l'emploi
l'utilisation en tout cas d envoi des
volontaires du service civique c'est pas
forcément une solution idoine se pose
pas tant d'ailleurs le problème delà de
la quantité de ces
de ces personnes mais plutôt de leur
qualité donc à choisir je préfère en
avoir un petit peu moins mais mieux
formés qu'avoir une masse disponible
mais qui pose des problèmes dans les
établissements autre dossier récurrent
pascal jean de nombreux néo titulaires
qui ont dû quitter la martinique faut
aller dans des postes à versailles à
créteil les académies on va dire de
rattachement de la martinique au grand
désarroi par exemple du snes qui
proposent bien que la guadeloupe
deviennent cette académie de
rattachement pour la martinique c'est
réalisable à la portée d'une proposition
c'est une proposition en soi mérite
d'être étudiée mais bien d'être étudiée
dans un cadre c'est que les personnes
qui passent un concours national par
définition sont affectés sur l'ensemble
du territoire national métropole comme
non métropole mais compte tenu de la
structure des emplois en réalité aux
antilles en guyane ou à la réunion ce
n'est pas que les antilles
évidemment la plupart si ce n'est la
totalité évidemment des lauréats se
retrouvant en métropole la question qui
est évoqué présente aussi un intérêt
mais il faudrait à la limite que je sois
saisie d'un dossier un peu plus
exhaustif que des mots
et les généralités on ne peut défendre
un dossier que lorsqu'il est argumentée
sérieusement argumenté parce que là on
déroge à une égalité en réalité et on
peut pas prôner à la fois l'égalité
et puis sur des cas particuliers
l'inégalité donc il faut il faut
argumenter ça ça peut se défendre je dis
pas que je défends cette idée mais en
tout cas je la regarderai avec
bienveillance
alors les grands chantiers monsieur le
recteur il y en a deux majeurs 1
il ya le lycée schoelcher qui avance on
a vu les grues installées dernièrement
et à la cité scolaire du bourg de sainte
marie sont des dossiers que vous suivez
est ce que pour cette marie par exemple
vous avez un agenda précis pour la
livraison du site sur ce dossier qui est
quand même très très technique un
évidemment il ya toujours des délais qui
sont annoncés dont j'ai pas de deux
dates butoirs chez vous les ans mais je
sais que les choses les choses avancent
bien et que ça devrait normalement être
dans l'est dans les délais qu'on était
qu'on était imparti la rentrée avec son
lot de nouveautés alors il ya eu
l'interdiction du téléphone portable
jusque dans les lycées ça existait déjà
dans les règlements intérieurs on va pas
ça trop s'arrêter là dessus l'autre
point qui alimente énormément les
discussions les débats notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux l'éducation sexuelle à
l'école que devons nous dire ce matin
dans ce sens qu'a dit pour rassurer tout
le monde
mais tout d'abord que c'est pas
l'éducation sexuelle c'est l'éducation à
la sexualité c'est pas un programme qui
est nouveau c'est un problème qui est
ancien il ya un certain nombre d'heures
qui est alloué à cette cette éducation à
la sexualité j'insiste bien il ne s'agit
il s'agit pas d'éduquer sexuellement les
enfants comprennent bien que c'est pas
ce débat tout simplement possible pour
l'éducation ça a jamais d'ailleurs été
l'intention de la ministre actuelle
comme des ministres précédents
il y a sur les réseaux sociaux ça
s'emballe très vite ça s'emballe très
vite et tout ce qui touche finalement à
de l'intimé parce que là on est sûr de
l'intimé on est sur du comportement on
est sur des relations très particulières
évidemment il suffit quelques
interprétations malveillantes par
rapport à des propos par rapport à la
loi en l'occurrence qui étaient ses
visées pour évidemment que ça se
répandent comme une traînée de poudre
mais ce que je veux c'est rassurer à la
fois les parents et les enseignants qui
sont mis en difficulté ou qui vont
pouvoir être humidifie côté exactement
donc là dessus on va voir la demande a
été faite par un syndicat de repousser
un report si vous voulez de de cet
enseignement
on va on va regarder si on peut si on
peut le faire en tout cas il est clair
que la doctrine de l'éducation ce n'est
absolument pas de l'éducation sexuelle
termes que d'ailleurs vous venez de
d'utiliser non c'est bien l'éducation à
la sexualité de prévention des risques
des maladies sexuellement transmissibles
les comportements dangereux
le sylar un mineur n'aura pas prouvé
qu'il était consentante et de
l'agression sexuelle mais est-ce que
c'est ce qu'avait été mis en avant sur
les réseaux sociaux
et oui et non mais on peut tout dire sur
les réseaux sociaux malheureusement les
beaucoup comme on appelle aujourd'hui de
fait knut et un mois je n'avais ni
reviendra mais ne faut plus belle on y
reviendra beaucoup plus longuement ce
sera 2 mai soit avec stéphanie tabia
d'impasse public qui fera sa rentrée en
télévision parcours sub pascal jean
échec ou réussite pour vous de
bacheliers sur trois ont trouvé
chaussure à leur pied pour la poursuite
de leurs études et le tiers qui restent
sur le carreau qui coûtait j'ai pas les
chiffres que vous avez ce que j'ai moins
comme chiffres c'est que 90 % des
bacheliers ont une proposition que près
de 80% honte accepté cette proposition
il reste que des cas qui sont
actuellement traités par la commission
d'accès à l'enseignement supérieur que
je préside chaque jeune aura une
solution
ça c'est une certitude dans ses rangs
écoutez la procédure se termine le 20 et
le 21 septembre
donc la difficulté dans cette procédure
c'est le temps et il faut se mettre à la
place des familles qui s'interrogent sur
le devenir
enfant louer un logement le transport en
fait ça sont des questions très
concrètes qui alimente djaidia l'anxiété
mais en tout cas en martinique il n'y a
pas d'inquiétude d'inquiétude
particulière à avoir ayant il reste
encore un certain nombre de places
vacantes
ma priorité étant de ne pas affecter en
priorité à l'université ce qui serait
facile et donc on aurait d'eschyle en
fin de formation à l'université mais
l'essentiel c'est quand même d'affecter
notamment dans les filières bts iut les
jeunes qui ont des bacs pros et des bacs
technologiques
c'est ça aussi les faire en sorte que ce
conte et bacs généraux ne viennent pas
forcément prendre la place de ceux qui
ont un bac qui était dédiée pour ce type
de filière donc c'est un choix les
parents peuvent être inquiet mais je
peux les rassurer il n'y aura pas de
difficulté particulière à ce sujet il y
aura des nouveautés le renforcement
dédoublements de classes dans le premier
degré le parcours anglais paix le
parcours anglais plus l'expression orale
libre est également resté quelques
secondes sur cette expression orale
libre c'est important que tout jeune dès
le plus jeune âge qu'on apprenne à
prendre la parole il sort de gagner en
confiance
le programme et ses dispositifs de réels
programmes à lille et il est assez
simple delà du cp à la terminale chaque
jour chaque jour un élève prendra la
parole pendant 5 minutes sur un sujet
libre sport je pas moins une épreuve de
foot un jeu vidéo va que sais je n'en
sais rien il choisira son sujet pendant
cinq minutes et s'exprimera l'enseignant
ne discute pas du fond avec l'élève
il ne fait que faire de la méthode
précise sa pensée l'amener arguments des
années à voir autrement l'amener à
préciser bref à ce qu ils structurent sa
pensée et de façon orale et à travers
sept
celle ce programme et hod il s'agit
aussi d'instaurer et de faire en sorte
que le jeune soit respectée en tant que
jeune il pense des choses il peut dire
les choses mais manquent la simplement
la différence c'est qu'après il ya un
moment donné
l'autorité revient vieux revient aux
professeurs donc l'idée c'est vraiment
ratoire c'est important mais c'est
fondamental
et c'est fondamental dans les cimes de
soi c'est fondamental dans
l'organisation sa pensée et je vous dire
en tant que parce que j'ai fait des
recrutements et dans le public et le
privé c'est aussi fondamental
aujourd'hui recrutement et on a trop de
jeunes j'ai trop vu de jeunes très
compétents ne pas décrocher un poste
tout simplement parce qu'il n'arrivait
pas à argumenter à motiver à structure
il faut que ça devienne un réflexe et ce
programme est mis en place dès la
rentrée
concrètement dès la toussaint puisqu'il
faut qu'ils aient les profs se se forme
en tout cas entre eux par rapport à 7 ce
programme viole merci d'avoir été avec
nous parce qu'à l'en remercions de
l'académie de martinique et bonne
rentrée à vous
[Musique]